[Music]
[Music]
13 US Chess Championships here at the
st. Louis chess club we're in round four
and yesterday we saw two clear winners
emerge in both of their respective
sections gata Kamsky leading the
championship by half a point with a
perfect 3o score and Irina crush leading
the US Women's Championship let's take a
look at the standings for the US Chess
Championship now round four coverage I'm
Jennifer Shahaji and with grandmasters
Jasser Sara Juan and Maurice Ashley just
as everyday we're going to be bringing
you up-to-the-minute analysis of these
games
yeah I'm looking forward to this round
for gata Kamsky as you mentioned perfect
score only one in the competition with a
shout of winning the Bobby Fischer prize
of $64,000 for a perfect result and then
we also have Conrad halt with two and a
half points and he's gonna be facing got
a Kamsky today in the Women's
Championship we've got Irene across half
a point ahead to the field with a
perfect 3o score fine Kings Indian
defense victory yesterday against Ana's
Akatsuki her main rival now her main
rival in this tournament may very well
be Tata Barbara me on who always really
brings her best chess to the US Women's
Championship and it's sitting on two and
a half out of three just a very very
short distance at the half a point
behind so it's a big match in those
games today around 4:00 and there we
have a webcam yes we've got a our big
game of the day in the championship
dad Akatsuki and Conrad halt in the u.s.
championship and we're going to pay
careful attention to that one and a
grand master Maurice Ashley has more for
us on key matchups of the day well very
strong collegiate presence already five
at least five players on the men's side
alone who just came off taking finals
and we know the stress of that and
having to jump into the waters with the
sharks at this tournament well they have
acquitted themselves quite well on the
top board we see 21 year old Conrad Holt
out of the University of Texas at Dallas
and he's on two and a half points
seeing gotta calm ski in the in this
round also the real surprise though is
FM feed a master John Bryant the only
player in the field without an
international master or international
Grandmaster title and he has surprised
everyone with two and a half points out
of three playing today against the bear
big liar big Larry Kristensen he's also
at the University of Texas at Dallas so
that school must know something and
there will be acquitting themselves
today trying to see if they can keep on
with this hot start Jenna gasps thank
you arias Jennifer let's just jump right
into Game one all right what do you
think shall we take it from the top
we have Conrad whole interesting Yankee
four and remember earlier in the
tournament that I can't ski chose to
play the Dutch defense right he got us
back to his favorite Slav that is to
provide by this move c7 c6
there we go and black is preparing to
capture this pawn and defend that pawn
with a move b5 and Conrad follows the
main lines and now a seven a six III all
very standard up to this movie this
movie 76 surprised me a lot and frankly
I don't think it's a good move let's put
it that way so many too many pawn your
the mixture because you've got the fan
kettle which isn't that typical in the
slop already and then you also have the
a6 move which is very specific right try
to play b5 in some positions and then
adding in addition to that a six you
just think it's true many system is
mixed up together yeah it looks like a
jumbled to begin with obviously B 7 B 5
it would have been the most standard
move even Bishop c8 f5 deserves
attention I just don't like this movie
7e 6 which basically locks in this
Bishop on
I see on c8 and the g7 one it's not
actually all that much better because
it's biting on granite on d4 for the
moment its future prospects are surely a
lot better than the one on c8 but still
remains to be seen you know from a
classical point of view if we had one of
our students lock their bishop in like
that we would say what are you doing
that's a big pond that is the big pond
of course gata Kamsky Grand Master
preparation has some specific reason
he's doing this but we we noticed that
in this tournament
it's not about big openings for him even
yesterday against Larry Christian saying
he got pretty much nothing out of the
opening that's right just played them
played Larry later in the game and again
strophe I believe as well you know he
played he played the leningrad against
they were letting Greg Koch against Rauf
so it's interesting to me that he's
playing against two different young guns
and kind of choosing diametrically
opposed openings against troph
he played a very dynamic opening and
against holt he's playing a much more
solid close to the best opening why do
you think that is do you think it's
because Holt is a stronger player even
though they're both young Holt is you
know four years older than Kaden and
he's already a grandmaster whereas Kaden
is still aspiring to that title and I am
at 14 certainly on his way but a little
bit less experienced yeah I just think
that God is feeling the tournament and
mixing his openings and defenses quite
okay again I just don't fully fathom or
understand this movie 76 as a classical
player I myself would just play e3 e4
opening up the avenue of this Bishop on
c1 if we were to see for example a trade
I just like these positions for white I
just think they're far more favorable
when this Bishop is stuck back there on
c8 I just like White's position very
very much oh sure I mean if you had four
if you were an e4 player or a d4 player
I imagine that if you knew that you
could get this position every game where
you know you have
your piece has developed into the
perfect squares and your opponent seems
like they have a couple weird moves a6
and e6
right we would sign up for that opening
for certainly without question so it's a
little bit it's a little bit puzzling
but I think what it is is also got a
Kamsky of course it's very serious about
this tournament I bet you keep studying
everybody's games in depth before he
plays them and maybe he noticed some
discomfort with halt and certain type of
position and tried to exploit it
we'll see Conrad played the move b2 b3
which that certainly is understandable
the bishop could come out here to the a3
being beyond a good diagonal rook e8
Bishop b2 hmm mystifying I don't
understand why the bishop is better on
b2 rather than a three and after Knight
bd7 Queen c2 okay normal defense
normal development by white as again why
I think should be angling for the
central pawn break III e4 b7 b6 finally
trying to bring this bishop into the
game with Bishop c8 - b7 followed by c5
and white to play let me just make sure
that I'm up to date with the latest
moves and we are so in a position like
this as it makes it it's very normal for
white to simply bring his rooks into the
center and we will determine hereafter
who stands better and why ok a little
slight edge for white shall we go take a
look at some of the other game Larry
Christensen versus John Bryan that's
gonna be a big game Oh without question
first of all John Bryant sitting at two
and a half out of three only 1/2 point
behind the leader gata Kamsky larry is
white interesting Larry can throw out
efore as well as d4 he chose d4 today we
have a
Queens gambit declined and then this
move Knight takes d5 recently it's a
defense that Vladimir Kramnik has been
championing on the black side as black
does get an opportunity to trade off two
pairs of pieces which makes it whoops
which makes it a little bit easier for
the second player on the other hand
White has occupied the center and got
the classical d4e for pawns and once
again we have some issues with that
Bishop on CA yes 96 and I think we're up
to date let me just double check this is
still all very standard play the the
most common way for white to play in
this variation is Bishop c4 then we
would see you move like castles castles
b6 d1 this should be 7 rook e1 still
deeply in theory Larry will be very
familiar with this setups for both sides
because he plays both sides in this
position absolutely and then we have
another game that I'm really excited
about on board 3 shava lover zona shoot
two players in the tournament who could
easily make a run I mean Shaba love just
an absolutely aggressive player who is
excelling in Swiss is where you have to
string a lot of wins together and it's
very dynamic and an ownership of course
a fantastic player who definitely could
challenge Kamsky and I think when both
of these guys play camps game it's gonna
be really interesting games well first
of all I'm delighted that Shaba has come
back he had that round one loss to God
right and it was really like shabath
felt like he had a big advantage coming
out of that opening and as he mentioned
French defense the French defense knight
on c5 and c4 and then gada ended up
giving up the two bishops and he had the
two knights against positions
Chavo I was happy with his opening he
was more than happy he really felt that
he let that game slip but Shaba came
back with two wins in two in a row one
lucky victory over [ __ ] gave some [ __ ]
gay and today he is white against the
number three seat
Oney shook stalwart of US team Olympic
teams and only shook apart me Alex with
chavala I should say with white plays
the Catalan and Alex is okay I'll
capture the pawn and knight c6 this is
one of the most challenging systems in
the Catalan when white captures this
pawn on c4 and most especially with this
move of b8 he says hey listen I want to
play B 7 B 5 and hold on to my
ill-gotten gains here with the pawn on
c4 I actually I've been playing some
blitz chess of late and I was playing
the black side of this variation this
move a4 followed by a5 is a very common
strategy and I was doing something very
weird here I was sacrificing this
exchange to just keep this pawn and some
light squares let me see exactly how I
was doing it I think I was doing yeah no
I was trying to win this light squared
Bishop a knight and I'm wondering why
I'm not leaving the a6 pawn on pretty
just an an idea of what I was trying to
do was to get some position like this
we're giving up the exchange in return
for cat for whites cattle and bishop but
I think I've mixed the moves apologies
for that 8 and 93 let me just make sure
that we're up to date with the moves
indeed Knight c3 was played so very
challenging
cheval off with this move Knight c3 now
I wonder what his intention is in case
black just plays b5 and says I want to
keep the pawn on c4 should white play a
line like this I'm not sure
Bishop c6 I can meet with a 6-4 very
sharp play for the moment white remains
a pawn down it's a question of what if
white can play Queen d4 and later win
that you can hold the play should be 7
their final position well we are gonna
take a quick break and be back with a
bunch more games in the round 4 of the
USS championship hello and welcome back
to 2013 us chess champion action we've
got got a Kamsky and conrad halt our key
game of the day here Yaser what do you
think well from the opening I thought
that Conrad played it a little too slow
delayed advance in this pawn III efore
and by the time he did this gada had
already developed his Bishop on b7 and I
think because of that delay got it is
now equalized the position this move f7
f5 was a very key move this Bishop on e4
is making it impossible for black to get
in the free move freeing advance c-65 f5
drove the bishop away and now this key
moves c5 opening up the bishop we were
saying earlier that Bishop 1c it was
gonna have trouble precisely the game
and here they go both bishops leaping
into action
and the only real issue for black being
that backward upon exactly and it's
gonna get solved probably immediately I
think white must feel compelled to play
the move Bishop e2 protecting the night
and also opening up the
for the rook and after for example a
move like Queen d7 takes on c5 Knight
takes e5 black secures this nice little
outpost on e4 and is ready to play 65 so
I think God is doing quite well I would
agree
I really like the kingside majority in
these types of positions if it's an end
game maybe we go for the Queen side
majority but in this middle game it's
it's just very fun to start pushing
those pawns and I think God is gonna
have fun in this division
now speaking of fun we like our
strategic battles but boy do we have a
slugfest
in the Women's Championship and
Grandmaster Ashley has more of that Jan
we love fighting games and there's no
more opening that's a titanic struggle
then the dragon it's been known for
years Bobby Fischer used to say you
don't throw the H pawn forward sac sac
and mate but the dragon aficionados have
been defending their fiery opening for
decades and today we see in this matchup
between Tata of Abraham hyun-woo who by
the way is in second place only a half a
point behind arena crush whose good
friend she's playing and arenas eniac
said there's no better friend in the
world than my friend arena crush and
she's now trying to hold back the main
rival that is Tata EV and they're
playing this incredible dragon what
makes the dragon so much fun well it's
because this King sits on this side of
the board in the yuccas lob the king
castles on this side and white goes to
castle on the other side so you see the
game proceeded with the march of the H
pawn here and then this move the Soltis
variation blocking the pawn and now
Queen to d2 and then rook to c8 jumping
to the open file and they're in mainline
territory castles and now Knight to e5
now you see both Kings on opposite sides
and Bishop to g5 the mainline rook to c5
you rarely see this stuff these days
King to be one and now b5 throwing the
pawn forward and white not to be denied
throwing her pawn forward and he
they go the pawns storm happening GTA h5
ripping the position open a for
attacking the bishop ignoring that at
age six pawn going forward this line is
absolutely crazy Bishop back to h8 and
now eight seven check more attacks now
Knight takes and after Bishop to d5 this
somewhat paradoxical moved to me Bishop
to g7 but they're playing quickly
they're playing a pace they're in the
main territory in the dragon crazy line
attacks somebody's gonna die today
that's what we love about this opening
it's such a fight totally unbalanced
terrific struggle we'll see how it goes
back to you Jenny yes and these two have
a history of duking it out in fact
talkative and then you also played a
dragon in 2009 and that was a Chinese
dragon whether with the Ruby 8 variation
exactly rook the a type move early on
very trendy at the time but now we have
a more traditional dragon just want to
try to pull it out sure dragons one of
my favorite openings well it's a massive
theoretical battle as Maurice was making
clear and also very clear to me that the
ladies are exceptionally well prepared I
can only imagine how much how many hours
of work must have gone into this
particular paddle before they got to the
board and what Maurice was saying is
both sides are attacking the respective
kings on opposite sides of the board
white plate age six age seven bishop
defy Bishop g7 again in such a tense
encounter this move Bishop g7 is really
kind of a slow move but okay the bishop
is obviously better on g7 is it worth an
entire tempo I'm not so sure
F for blowing this Knight out of its
happy outpost on e5 and I guess that's
the latest in this theoretical battle I
would reckon Knight c4
I think 94 will happen and then it's a
question to be queen
yeah do we play Queen z2 here that would
run in tonight 83 I just I'm trying to
like get on that g6 pawn or we might
have to go all the way to h2 or we could
take the knight I mean taking the knight
is usually the first thing to consider
like this yeah maybe rook takes
attacking this knight on d4 waits
getting like blacks getting tons of
counter play very quickly yes yes it's
weird I'm just it's such a sharp
position the diagonal also if I can just
consider playing the weird-looking f6
which does track the bishop one g5 okay
that's another one to be concerned about
right with a knight here being attacked
let's go back one maybe just queen h2
with the the idea that maybe we're gonna
get there first
normally letting that night live on c4
is very dangerous in there I again and
you kind of instinctively take it off
but boy Weiss exactly just becoming
faster yeah you want to immediately well
I'm not sure I always yeah you have to
look at these kinds of moves like Knight
a3 check when that knight on c3 is only
guarded I merely guarded by this pawn on
b2 so imagine a knight a 3 check with
the idea of playing B 5 B 4
this could get scary for white as well I
mean anybody that's why of anybody's
game oh yeah yeah I mean that's one
candidate move that's in and then also
the the Queen a5 and IP to ideas and
you're right even taking on b2
immediately is worth calculating because
after King b2 you can even look at a
three or worth takes c3 with the idea of
Queen a5 check right I mean all these
things need to be checked
well I tell you that the only way I
would want to enter this variation with
either color is to
be well well-prepared put it in an
engine and having given that a great
deal of preparation this is a extremely
sharp line where every move is telling I
think I think octave it's probably
better prepared in this tournament so I
would have to give the edge to her in
this in this game I think she excels in
these types of attacking positions and I
have a feeling that uh she has some
great preparation here I know that she
takes his tournament extremely serious
so let's see if queen h2 my issue is
what if like she just ignores anything
that black does and plays h5
I mean like how fast are we getting
there and you know it's like not that
far from checkmate
great if you play if we play Queen h2
and you play even if you play Knight B -
what if we even ignore that and just
play h5
I mean how fast is this does this train
calm good question I mean I do you wanna
that we take on g6 I mean make c3 King
anyone like aren't we close to meeting
you well as maurices mentioned the
dragon is one of those variations that
has more lives than a cat yeah I'll just
point out one defensive idea for black I
know it's painful but check this out
terrible to block the h-file just when
you're absolutely sure you're ready to
deliver checkmate I mean grab but we
can't grab on h7 but then your ideas
just play King h8 and squirrel away
there right well the pawn axe act
actually is a protection for the black
King so we can't just be so cavalier and
sacrifice everything we need to find the
perfect defensive move and then go for
the onslaught but it does feel like
White's attack it's coming faster than
black but you know it always feels that
way in the dragon and that's why Bobby
Fischer famously said that it's a very
dangerous opening to play against lower
rate of players playing against the
player 400 points or lower rater than
you dragon it's like one of the biggest
losers like you just don't want it
because it's such a tactical melee and
it can be decided so quickly and the
moves can tend to be clearer for white a
little bit more obvious you think that
if you uh if you play it again somebody
much weaker you might just find yourself
getting up
I remember in the 80s and 90s that Tony
miles a very famous Grandmaster from the
UK was doing horrible things to the
white players he was a little bit ahead
of his time in terms of his preparation
he was playing the black side of the
Dragon and these this defense you know
it's all about preparation
and in this particular case I do think
that Queen h2 does lead to this kind of
crash and burn type of attack with maybe
Knight takes b2 if we play okay so
instead of going h5 which I agree might
be a little bit too fast what if we just
take the knight
okay and let's go with just the director
yeah you had mentioned ago because I I
noticed that if I play King b2 you have
a queen before Jack and now you're
you're hitting my my knight on d4 a
number of times but then I noticed that
maybe what about the deep what about
King b3 that's why King David 3 yeah
that's why I like wasn't 100% sure the
King d3 mm-hmm
I guess we're only down a rook here for
black mercy aide yes that's very normal
trying to take advantage of the C 3
square perhaps yeah it's tricky because
you know our threat is something like
work C 3 chat can you - Bishop takes d4
and then we play Brook take c2 and when
you're Queen on H tail okay and it's
actually not that easy to stop it seems
because anything you move destroys
another defense doesn't it like if you
play an 82 then it opens up our Bishop
on c3 and I can play there rook c3 check
anyway
maybe not no I guess I can't you're
gonna run huh that's a bit too much but
after an 82 I probably have something
better what do we have instead hmm
something good no doubt just be
just just a quiet move like beefy for to
get our Bishop into the attack or well
III okay I was waiting for you to prompt
me with that Bishop b5 check how about
if I continue with the idea of checkmate
on the Kings side and you have opened up
this should be five check but as you
mentioned just a moment ago I'm ready to
run and run I think Maurice is pointing
out a better move something with maybe
after in this position dude do play
works III so works III and then after
after Knight c3 to capture with the
Queen one eye and now Bishop g4 okay
that yeah that's what we missed we
stopped looking at at this position but
actually Bishop g4 very strong bring you
one more piece into the attack exactly
yes and then when we actually when we
take on d1 it's also gonna leave that
Queen on h2 unprotected so you're not
even gonna be able to recapture it
well actually I'm afraid that's what you
have to Queen f3 Jack right so that's
just gonna be disastrous
so that just simply doesn't work
so here hmm maybe it's time to to hitch
our ride right away or should I
oh boy I'm not sure maybe I should block
this whole C file action movie Queen d2
it's a little bit more defensive minded
to protect the square C 3 so we're down
a rook so if we capture on d2 to and
take on d4 we're still gonna be down in
exchange right oh I'm sorry you just
take with the rock excuse me so
we'd have to have to keep pieces on the
board yeah definitely here so yeah I
think you're right so the move before
seems correct threatening works III
mm-hmm and also a moment ago there was
that variation where the bishop was
coming to g4 still if I get on my
bicycle and try to run away if you get
on your bicycle and you try to run away
we probably play works III check okay
and by the way you had pointed out that
White's bishops all right
like on ideal squares at a certain
moment you might want to try to simply
win one of them but okay rooks III check
I understand you've got to look at the
checks first always check it may be made
I see what you're saying like at some
point we can basically just bail out and
play e6 and try to win one of your
offending bishops right right because
it's just gonna be very hard for the
bishop to play anywhere all right like
if it goes to b7 the only free square we
can even play a Queen b6 or Queen a7
Titan move and exactly taking advantage
of the pin on d4 so extremely
complicated but looking like a very
downward trend for life yeah well again
maybe we were wrong I mean my my first
instinct was taught to his preparation
here was better so like I favored her
but after Knight to c4 maybe we have to
go back to this takes c4 idea rather
than the Queen h2 which falls into that
Knight takes B to C for I didn't like
because it just seemed so direct
outfitter work takes you for I that
you're threatening a Tuesday for and you
might be finding xx exactly that just
seemed like too much but I was thinking
that white should just keep her Queen
hovering around the c3 square maybe
something like Queen to d3 and I'm
seeing that this is falling for a very
different kind of a tactic that you
don't often see in a dragon where
Knight comes to be to forking Queen and
rook having a lot of fun here at the
u.s. Chess Championship and we're gonna
just take a quick break to try to make
the viewing experience even smoother for
our lovely viewers at home excellent